bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo votre rendez-vous avec l'actualité
politique et parlementaire de la semaine
bonjour ml
au menu aujourd'hui la polémique de
cette semaine total l'entreprise aux 14
milliards de bénéfices qui annonce la
suppression de 500 emplois dans le
raffinage
autre choc la plus importante fermeture
des usines depuis le début de la crise
celle du fabricant de pneus continental
11 cents salariés internet
la coupure d'abonnement pour
téléchargements illégaux et contesté
jusque dans les rangs de la majorité
texte dépasser ou équilibrer le projet
de loi électrise l'assemblée nationale
et suscite même quelques dérapages
et puis la préparation des élections
européennes les partis se mettent en
ordre de marche pour la campagne vote
des militants sur les têtes de listes au
ps ça passe sauf dans une région la
région centre où le parachutage du
fabiusien henri weber n'est pas du goût
des militants précisément d'ailleurs
pour revenir sur toute cette actualité
notre invité cette semaine emilie c'est
laurent fabius bienvenue à vous vous
avez joué le vieux sage mais les vieux
sage actif et je crois que cette
expression est la réponse du viol alors
un grand sage actif par ailleurs ancien
plus jeunes premiers mise de la vème
république le chantre du non à l'europe
lors du référendum de démission au
référendum européen de 2005 j'étais sûr
que j'allais me reprendre et puis par
ailleurs et là vous ne reprendrait pas
candidat malheureux pour les primaires
socialistes c'était à l'occasion de la
présidentielle de 2007 alors il
semblerait que depuis quelques mois vous
retrouver ou vous reprenez goût à la
lumière et cette lumière c'est vrai
qu'elle est d'abord parlementaire vous
avez été l'orateur principal des
socialistes lors de la première motion
de censure de l'ère sarkozy et puis il
paraît que vous êtes très actif lors des
réunions du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée je me suis laissé dire vous
aviez même envie de prendre peut-être
deux volets la présidence du groupe à
jean marc ayrault l'été prochain vous
confirmer ou non il n'y a pas de vols de
l'or c'est vrai que je suis actif tout
simplement je fais mon jeu rempli mon
rôle de parlementaire c'est une fonction
que j'ai toujours
adoré parce que c'est ici dans le
parlement que bâle coeur de la
démocratie j'essaie de faire mon travail
le mieux possible
je suis candidat c'est pas du tout
candidat à tel ou tel poste
mais la fonction groupe socialiste bien
sûr mais en revanche je suis candidat
pour m'exprimer sur les grands textes et
par exemple la semaine prochaine ce
portrait la parole des socialistes sur
la réintégration dans l'otan
qu'est ce qui pour vous a changé au
parti socialiste depuis l'arrivée de
martine aubry à la tête
je pense que au niveau national le parti
s'est remis au travail ce qui était
absolument indispensable alors qu' il y
avait un certain temps tout de même que
le travail n'était pas suffisant je
crois que au delà de telle ou telle
consultation sur telle ou telle liste
européenne postérieur c'est toujours
difficile mais il y a tout de même un
meilleur rassemblement que cet état dans
le passé et asynchrone
martine aubry elle même je pense qu'elle
a tout à fait les épaules pour remplir
cette fonction
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai
soutenu et que je la soutiens et puis ce
qui est encourageant c'est que la ligne
politique est beaucoup plus clair
qu'elle n'était avant c'était une ligne
d'opposition tout avait fermé à monsieur
sarkozy mais en même temps de
propositions parce qu'il faut cumuler
les deux choses vous frappent leurs
proches de contester me donne plus
proposés il faut faire les deux
d'ailleurs je vais faire un peu de
publicité
j'ai moi même un blog que j'ai appelé 50
50 pour dire que j'essaye pour ma part
de faire procès nécessaire 50% critique
et 50% de propositions parce que dans la
critique on est on est souvent très bon
mais a juste titre mais après les gens
dégoûtés d'accord mais vous êtes un
parti de gouvernement vous aspirez à
responsabilité du poids donc quelles
sont vos propositions je crois qu'il
faut y répondre
voilà on va parcourir avec vous
l'actualité de cette semaine lundi tout
d'abord et les européennes les partis se
mettent en ordre de marche
oui en ce début de semaine on commence à
y voir un peu plus clair pour cette
campagne des élections européennes qui
se précisent les partis se mettent
progressivement en ordre de marche
même s'il existe encore quelques petits
tiraillements et notamment chez les
socialistes tout de suite quand les
partis se mettre sur la ligne de départ
c'est un sujet signe anaïs booba tient à
l'ump ambiance by paul est la star du
jour c'est elle rachida dati on le sait
à la garde des sceaux se tourner vers
l'europe en traînant des pieds mais sa
popularité reste intacte
deux ministres têtes de liste en
ile-de-france michel barnier et européen
convaincu même si au départ le ministre
de l'agriculture avait affiché sa
préférence pour la région sud est
nous allons faire une campagne et craché
d'adapter très dynamique
nous sommes heureux fier qu'on me fasse
confiance pour animer cette campagne je
le suis en particulier puisque j'ai des
racines dans une autre partie de la
france mais je suis très heureux
jeu pour faire allusion à une phrase que
j'ai entendu récemment je suis là de mon
plein gré au nouveau centre l'ambiance
est plus calme
par crainte de mauvais résultats les
dirigeantes du parti centriste ont
décidé de ne pas présenter de liste
autonome
ils partent donc en campagne aux côtés
de leurs alliés de l'ump ce que nous
pensons c'est que dans un contexte comme
celui ci
vient la majorité a besoin d'être unie
pour partir en campagne
pour partir en campagne pour défendre
notre projet européen
ce que nous ferons
même temps pour défendre la politique
réformatrice depuis 22 mois avec
partenaire de l'ump le nouveau centre a
obtenu ce qu'il voulait trois candidats
en position éligible sur des listes ump
jean-marie cavada devrait obtenir la
troisième place en ile-de-france
derrière michel barnier et rachida dati
lancement de la campagne du front de
gauche 6 mille personnes venues pour
applaudir un début de rassemblement créé
sur la base du non de gauche au traité
européen de 2005 le front ne réunit pour
l'instant que le parti communiste et le
parti de gauche jean-luc mélenchon ya
plein de gens qui remettent en cause
leurs certitudes dont qu'ils écoutent le
message de la gauche et de la gauche qui
se tient droit un bal à gauche serpent
là on sait pas très bien ce que c'est ni
chair ni poisson là ils auraient ils
entendent bien notre discours
vous savez le meilleur symptômes de ça
c'est le nom de janvier ici qu'est ce
que vous croyez que c'est les gens sont
librement
invité surprise christian picquet figure
de la lcr devenue npa en désaccord avec
la direction de son parti
pour l'instant le parti d'olivier
besancenot refuse tout accord pour les
européennes et garde ses distances avec
le front de gauche
sauf surprise le npa ira seule aux
européennes voilà donc votre ami henri
weber a eu quelques déconvenues en
région centre cette semaine c'est quoi
ces problèmes d'un parachutage d'un
fabusien dans cet endroit là de la
france je ne pense pas c'est d'abord
extrêmement difficile de bâtir des
listes parce que je crois que chez nous
les socialistes qui avaient mille mille
candidats et donc il y a eu une
délibération collective entre les deux
sens au dirigeant qui sont dirigeants
élus et il ya des listes qui ont été
arrêtés puis qui ont été proposés bien
sûr aux militants la l'immense majorité
de ces listes a été soutenue a été
approuvé il ya dans un ensemble de
régions une région le limousin qui parce
qu'elle n'avait pas de candidat sur
cette liste d'après ce que j'ai compris
a voté contre dont ça va être bien
évidemment examiné par de nouveaux une
convention nationale mais ça ne mettra
pas en cause
henri weber qui n'était pas en cause est
ce que quand même ça ça fait pas un peu
ps ancienne manière on a le sentiment
que ces listes a été composé avec les
dosages des courants ou des sociétés un
renouvellement et bien sûr mais il ya
des règles qui ont été posées qui sont à
ses nouvelles par exemple
nous n'autorisons pas le cumul excessive
demande à l'homme si vous êtes président
de département auprès d'andré gens vous
pouvez pas être en même temps
parlementaire européenne
c'est une règle nouvelle et puis il y à
un certain nombre de députés qu peuvent
se représenter mais on a voulu aussi
renouveler les listes et puis à la
diversité à la fois bien sûr une femme
ça c'est normal cours à la loire et puis
à les sensibilités qui peuvent exister
bon mais je vous répète c'était un 6
très compliqué mais enfin dans l'immense
majorité des cas ça a été approuvé donc
voilà maintenant si je veux vous avez
envie de jouer quel rôle dans ces
européennes vous impliquez comment ça va
être quoi lâche enfin nombre de réunions
pour épauler les listes bien sûr nous a
également parlé d'europe où on va
surtout de taper sur nicolas sarkozy à
l'occasion de cette campagne
je pense que comme dans toute élection
il y aura européenne il y aura un double
aspect évidemment désigne des
parlementaires européens a donc c'est
une certaine vision de l'europe
et en ce qui nous concerne c'est une
europe différente de ces petites sur lui
beaucoup plus social beaucoup plus
écologique beaucoup plus tournée vers
l'emploi
mais il y aura aussi cet aspect sanction
non seulement de la mauvaise politique
de monsieur sarkozy mais également de
son correspondant au niveau européen
monsieur barroso et donc je crois que
les électeurs diront à la fois oui à une
europe différente et non à la politique
ça fait un tournant pour le ps ces
élections tournant je crois pas mais
enfin il faut à vivre mais nous allons
je crois mieux même s'il ya encore des
progrès à faire
voilà un autre sujet dans l'actualité du
début de la semaine promise par jacques
chirac la baisse de la tva sur la
restauration va enfin être possible à
ministre d'économie arrive pourtant
prudente lundi au conseil des ministres
de l'union à bruxelles c'est le ministre
des finances l'allemagne qui s'est
longtemps opposée à cette possibilité de
cette fois son feu vert après des heures
de discussions
finalement la france obtient un accord
pour permettre ce taux réduit alors qui
sera gagnant dans cette affaire
réaction avec antoine de maison
dans ce restaurant du quartier des
affaires de paris la baisse de la tva
est attendue depuis longtemps
pour sylvie la patronne le calcul est
vite fait pas question de baisser les
prix en cas de réduction de la tva il
s'agirait plutôt t'embauche et plus de
personnel ou de mieux s'équiper
une autre façon de satisfaire le client
ça nous permettrait de pouvoir employer
de nouveaux et puis surtout axé cette
différence sur les investissements voilà
beaucoup de restaurants n'ont pas leur
cuisine aux normes
on a beaucoup de choses à améliorer
tantôt niveau des services au niveau de
la qualité pas de ristourne sur
l'addition mais un meilleur service
un effort insuffisant pour les
associations de consommateurs qui
veulent profiter directement de ses
points de tva grappiller à bruxelles il
faut que chacun s'y retrouve
c'est à dire que si on peut comprendre
que la totalité de la baisse ne soit pas
affectée au prix qu'ils peuvent payer
par les consommateurs or je dirais qu'il
faut qu'il y ait un partage des gains
entre guillemets prime embauche
investissements autant de répercussions
qui ne profiteront pas directement aux
consommateurs en cas de baisse de la tva
le principal gagnant serait évidemment
le secteur de la restauration un secteur
qui emploie près d'un million de
personnes en france
laurent fabius avec cette revendication
de la baisse de la tva dans la
restauration c'est un vieux serpent de
mer française qu'il faut reconnaître à
nicolas sarkozy le mérite de n'avoir pas
lâché sur cette question et finalement
l'être plus ou moins parvenu à ses fins
je ne sais pas parce que on verra le
madame madère qui est le représentant
des consommateurs pose bien la question
on verra à qui ça profite
bon d'abord il faut quand même dire
honnêtement parce que faut pas faire de
démagogie que ça va coûter quand même
pas mal de milliards d'euros les
milliards d'euros enfin dans les pays
cela sera peut-être pas 5,5 plutôt
disent oui mais enfin les milliards
d'euros il faut les trouver et est donc
ça veut dire probablement des impôts
supplémentaires mais mis à part cet
aspect qu'il faut en avoir mais moi la
question est qu'est-ce qui va en
bénéficier
alors là vous avez plusieurs écoles vous
avez disons l'école du bonze france si
vous interrogez les gens viennent et est
ce que vous êtes pour la baisse de tva
dit oui parce que les additions vont
baisser et ça va être pour nous les
consommateurs mais les restaurateurs ont
peut-être une vision différente en
disant ah mais nous sommes en difficulté
donc ça va être plutôt pour nos
investissements riera et
c'est plutôt favorable aux baisses de
tva penser que ça a des effets positifs
sur lui mais d'ailleurs c'est un peu
paradoxal puisque monsieur sarkozy
monsieur fillon nous ont expliqué que
c'était stupide et il trouve ses
formidables lorsqu'il s'agit de la
restauration s'est passé du corporatisme
décès non je crois que au fond c'était
monsieur chirac je crois qu'il y avait
agi dans ce sens là mais au fur et à
mesure que la difficulté de la situation
économique en france a été plus
difficile
le gouvernement soutenait cette
revendication en espérant qu'elles ne
seraient pas satisfaites
et quand on suit attentivement les
travaux de bus peaucelle on s'aperçoit
que c'est un peu le cas et puis là bon
elle est satisfaite mais maintenant la
question est à qui ça va profiter et je
pense pour ma part tout en reconnaissant
les difficultés du secteur que si ça a
lieu ça doit profiter d'abord sur
l'addition consommateurs beaucoup de
discussions en europe autour de cette
question sur un plan beaucoup plus large
cette fois on a vu cette semaine tout un
débat sur les paradis fiscaux le secret
bancaire qui avance puisque même la
suisse est prête à faire des concessions
là dessus angela merkel et nicolas
sarkozy semble avoir agi main dans la
main si je veux dire c'est une bonne
chose
on va voir tout ça au sommet de londres
qui a lieu au début avril parce qu'il ya
g va donc les vingt 20 grandes nations
qui se réunit et qui normalement doivent
prendre des décisions en matière de
régulation
lundi fiscaux en font partie moi je
connais très bien ce sujet que j'ai
traité lorsque je m'occupais des
finances du pays et je sais qu'il ne
faut pour ta jument que lorsque les
résultats sont là pour le moment c'est
des discussions bon et moi j'avais fait
une proposition je le redis ici puisque
le gouvernement a fourni des capitaux
importants à nos établissements
bancaires je pense que quand on fonde
les capitaux il faut exiger des
contreparties et je trouverais excellent
en montrant l'exemple que l'on dise à
nos établissements pour bancaire et bien
rond paie donc les relations avec les
paradis fiscaux
l'allemagne plupart travaillent avec des
peintures sculptures l'allemagne
pourrait faire la même chose et à ce
moment là on arriverait beaucoup plus
fort à londres parce qu'on pourrait dire
écoutez c'est faisable à preuve c'est
que nous l'avons fait donc j'attends
encore cela n'a part du gouvernement
lesage à temps et réfléchie en face en
attendant la journée
mardi à mardi sous le signe des pirates
du net
un email pour vous tirer les oreilles
puis un courrier recommandé enfin si
vous continuez de jouer est les rebelles
ont suspendra carrément votre abonnement
internet voilà ce qui vous attend si
vous êtes un pirate du net adeptes de
téléchargements illégaux
alors tout de suite le détail de ce
projet de loi qui a été examiné toute la
semaine à l'assemblée avec germain
andrieu la loi création et internet est
plus connu sous le nom d'hadopi la haute
autorité pour la diffusion des oeuvres
et la protection des droits sur internet
elle devrait être mise en place avant
l'été prochain l'objectif de cette
nouvelle loi n'a pas changé
lutter contre les téléchargements
illégaux grâce à des ripostes graduées
en clair une fois l'infraction constatée
l'hadopi enverra d'abord aux internautes
d avertissement par e-mail puis des
lettres recommandées
si les téléchargements illégaux persiste
la haute autorité pourra sanctionner
l'internaute par une suspension
provisoire de son abonnement internet
la france compte aujourd'hui près de 17
millions d'abonnés internet à haut débit
près de dix mille identification par
jour sont prévus selon les hypothèses
d'un rapport de bercy
l'hadopi pourrait priver le web environ
180 mille internautes chaque année alors
c'est vrai qu'on a entendu les
socialistes très actif sur ce thème
cette semaine qu'ils disent en gros
c'est un texte d'un autre temps qui sera
périmée ou dépasser d'ici six mois
5 en même temps pourra dire que pour la
première fois les politiques ont pris le
taureau par les cornes sur un sujet
complexe cet événement très compliqué
parce que vous avez deux postulations
qui sont qui s'entrechoquent
vous avez d'un côté les créateurs qui
très légitimement veulent que leurs
oeuvres soient protégés et de l'autre
vous avez les internautes vous êtes dont
je suis et qui veulent le pouvoir
pianoter librement et
c'est en particulier c'est pas
illégalement et on comprenait ça alors
moi je suis quand même un peu gêné dans
la proposition du gouvernement par deux
aspects bon premier aspect c'est que je
me suis laissé dire par des spécialistes
que les mécanismes qui sont mis en
oeuvre qui sont prévus pour empêcher le
téléchargement illégal illégal pardon
pouvez quand même être contournée donc
je suis pas sûr que ce soit très
efficace
deuxième aspect c'est que en fait il
n'ya pas de moyens supplémentaires qui
vont aller à la création or si ce
système est bizarre c'est quand même
pour aider la création
et puis moi j'ai rencontré beaucoup
d'internautes à partir de jeunes qui
sont très choqués par cet élément là
donc je crois nous nous avons pris à
l'assemblée nationale les socialistes
position contre que le texte est je
pense qu'il faudrait quand même le
réexaminer le site une loi pour rien
c'est la crainte
enfin pour rien non parce qu'elle a
quand même déclencher une cité très vive
donc de ce point de vue là c'est pas
neutre mais je me demande si elle va pas
si elle est adoptée passé à côté de son
objectif
l'actualité économique et social avec le
dossier total des bénéfices records mais
des suppressions d'emplois la direction
du groupe pétrolier annonce 300 postes
en moins dans le raffinage d'ici à 2013
deux cent concernent directement la
raffinerie de gonfreville en
seine-maritime
cette annonce suscite la colère parmi
les salariés l'indignation même du
secrétaire d'état à l'emploi laurent
wauquiez pour qui c'est une décision
scandaleuse julia le correct une annonce
qui fait tache en temps de crise
suppression de 555 postes au sein du
groupe total
alors qu'en 2008 le groupe a dégagé le
plus gros profit jamais réalisé par un
groupe français
une annonce condamné dans une relative
unanimité cet après midi laurent
wauquiez le secrétaire d'état à l'emploi
visiblement choqué je le dis comme je le
pense ça me reste en travers de la gorge
et je trouve que total devrait
trail exemple et je pense que pour leur
image de marque ce serait mieux et c'est
ce qu'on va essayer de faire c'est de
leur expliquer que dans cette période de
crise un groupe qui fait des milliards
d'euros peut faire un petit geste pour
500 salariés en france
concrètement au sein de l'opposition
s'est aussi l'indignation et le parti
socialiste en profite pour tacler la
politique du gouvernement ont quitté les
grands groupes qui font des bénéfices
devrait donner l'exemple alors trouver
des solutions pour préserver l'encours
parce que j'espère bien que la crise
durera le moins longtemps possible même
si elle est due pour beaucoup alors si
les grands groupes
bon dans cette direction vous imaginez
les petites et moyennes entreprises qui
ont elles à faire face à d'énormes
difficultés rick j'ai entendu le
secrétaire d'état à l'emploi creed et le
lancer des cris d'orfraie moi ça
m'intéresse pas ce qui m'intéresse c'est
l'action
le parti communiste lui reste toujours
sur ses positions pour marie george
buffet il est temps d'interdire les
licenciements
on ne peut pas admettre qu'aujourd'hui
au pays des dividendes de mon épée
actionner et qu'on fiche à la rue des
hommes et des femmes qui au produit ces
déchets ce par leur travail
le gouvernement demande au groupe
d'avoir un comportement exemplaire et
attendons aujourd'hui des réponses de la
direction de total alors justement
laurent fabius
le gouvernement a eu la bonne réaction
écoutez les résultats moi je suis
d'autant plus sensible à tout ça que
c'est dans ma région dans mon
département et que je peux confirmer que
ça a été un choc
c'est un choc énorme parce que total est
très présent on sait effectivement les
profits considérables qui réalise et là
les gens se disent alors quoi si même un
groupe comme ça supprime
des emplois où va-t-on donc il réalise
pas en france en fait il est réalisé à
l'étranger
oui donc nous sommes intervenus avec mon
collègue et ami le président du
département didier marie pour demander à
la direction de total à la fois de faire
en sorte qu'ils n'aient aucun
licenciement
c'est très important ici est engagé oui
enfin ce à quoi je crois c'est quand
c'est noir sur blanc parce qu'avant
c'est des paroles verbales et qu'il y
ait une action économique très puissante
dans la région y compris avec les sous
traitants etc
et puis qu' il y ait les perspectives de
développement qui soit beaucoup plus
forte capable de toute façon la matière
une impuissance des politiques ou alors
il faut dire comme argent fait qu'on
interdit les lys en gagnant non mais de
toutes les manières dans le kop total et
au delà du cas de total
moi je pense qu'il faut être beaucoup
plus exigeant sur quoi premièrement dans
des situations comme celle-là s'il ya eu
des aides publiques il faut le
remboursement des êtres humains
deuxièmement il faut évidemment que il y
est une solution individuelle pour
chaque salarié
et troisièmement il faut qu'il y ait su
à la charge des groupes surtout les
groupes très bénéficiaires comme cela
une réindustrialisation du site
si on ne fait pas ça et c'est ce qui me
frappe pour un député sur le terrain
vous allez avoir une révolte des jambes
parce que quand vous additionnez total
continental on en parlera peut-être
toute une série moi je vois dans ma
propre région johnson and johnson
glaxo enfin dans tous les secteurs plus
les petites entreprises dont vous
entendez pas parlé parce que c'est dit
personne ici 50 personnes là les gens
sont désespérés en particulier les
jeunes
donc vous prenez plutôt l'accompagnement
vous n'allez pas jusqu'à remettre en
cause ce qui est vécu par les
entreprises comme une nécessité
nous allons maintenant de temps en temps
pour être clair on profite de la crise
c'est dire il ya des secteurs où il ya
plus de marché bon vous pouvez pas
produire des voitures si personne ne
vous les achète bon encore faut-il quand
on a la possibilité
accompagné tout ça socialement et dans
beaucoup de cas s'y opposer parce qu' un
certain nombre de groupes profitent de
la crise pour faire des choses qui ne
sont pas intéressants jusqu'à vouloir
rétablir une forme d'autorisation
administrative des ans mais je pense
qu'il faut un contrôle très précis des
motifs de licenciement comme très précis
en disant tout simplement qu' il faut
qu'il y est un bien fondé économique
financier et ça peut pas être je
licencie parce que je licencie c'est
possible nous allons passer maintenant
l'actualité de mercredi avec un nouveau
temps pour l'otan
oui pour certains c'est un changement de
cap radical de la politique étrangère
française pour d'autres c'est seulement
la continuation d'un processus enclenché
dans les années 90 le retour de la
france dans le commandement militaire
intégré de l'otan a été confirmée
mercredi par nicolas sarkozy en écoute
tout de suite le chef de l'état le
rapprochement avec l'otan conforte
l'indépendance nationale notre
éloignement proclamé mais non réalisé
avec le temps limite notre indépendance
nationale et nos marges de manoeuvre le
moment est donc venu de mettre fin à
cette situation car c'est l'intérêt de
la france et c'est l'intérêt de l'europe
en concluant ce long processus la france
sera plus forte
la france sera plus influentes pourquoi
parce que les absents ont toujours tort
parce que la france doit codiriger
plutôt que subir c'est l'idée que je me
fais de la france alors on a vu toute la
semaine le sujet divise à droite à
gauche vous avez certainement lu le
figaro de mercredi qui explique
finalement avec ses propos de nicolas
sarkozy on prolongeait simplement un
processus amorcé par françois mitterrand
à la fin des années 90
oui j'ai lu aussi la réponse comme
beauvais la de hubert védrine jean louis
bianco de dix ans c'était un mensonge et
sont probablement assez bien placé pour
le dire puisqu'il était ce ratage est
enlisé non je pense que c'est un sujet
très important très fondamentale
gimbernat d'ailleurs au au nom du groupe
socialiste cette semaine pour dire ce
que nous en pensons
mais c'est tout de même
assez paradoxal que ce soit prétendu
gaulliste c'est sarkozy qui enterre le
gaullisme c'est quoi les conséquences
concrètes de cette décision sont les
conséquences concrètes
je pense que ça réduira l'influencé de
la france parce que auprès de tous nos
partenaires à travers le monde
la france est un pays qui n'est pas
alignée sur un bloc est là qu on le
veuille ou non c'est ça aujourd'hui les
états unis de barack obama
oui mais la décision a été prise dans
les états unis de monsieur bush
alors aujourd'hui on nous dit que
c'était avec monsieur obama c'est pas
vrai donc je crains je crains que cela
ne réduisent notre influence
premièrement et deuxièmement quand
j'entends l'argumentation mais ça va
permettre de développer la défense
européenne je crains que ce soit
exactement l'inversé
car si même la france qui était attachée
à la défense européennes s'alignent en
matière de temps pourquoi voudriez vous
que les autres pays l'europe
tout d'un coup protégé par les
américains à travers le temps fasse en
plus un effort et notamment financiers
nécessaires pour bâtir une défense
européenne vous renoncerez contre 7
certainement ce retour dans le seul
élément à maigret manière argumentée
alors on pourra dire mais vous êtes de
gauche vous êtes de l'opposition c'est
normal oui mais attention des voix qui
sont quand même des voix qu'on doit
entendre au-delà des aspects politiques
comme celle de monsieur juppé celle de
monsieur de villepin
celle d'un certain nombre de
responsables de droite du centre
rejoignent notre point de vue cette
bande reste algie d'une forme de
gaulliste qui est un peu dépassé la
france de 2009 n'est pas celle de 64 ça
je l'avais remarqué aux fins de 66 en
tout cas et 6 mai
ça c'est un raisonnement que chéri mais
c'est sarkozy que j'appelle le
raisonnement des fausses évidences ces
airs qui dit la situation n'est pas la
même
bien sûr d'avoir sa licence pourra
constater ça mais c'est pas la question
la question est est ce que dans la
situation nous sommes nous avons intérêt
à modifier notre position or sans
rentrer dans le détail je le ferais
mardi au moment où général de gaulle
prend sa décision et c'est le côté très
anticipate r d de gaulle il le prend il
la prend pour différentes raisons et
notamment parce qu'ils refusent la
logique des blocs et veut un monde
multipolaire
c'est exactement ce à quoi nous voulons
aller aujourd'hui alors est ce que c'est
le moment
alors même que la multipolarité s'impose
de revenir sur ce qui est une
spécificité de la france voilà le début
du débat dans l'hémicycle puisque le
débat sera bien sûr retransmis en direct
sur la chaîne parlementaire et mercredi
l'assemblée nationale a voté le projet
de loi sur l'hôpital et la santé le
dernier volet a fait beaucoup débat avec
des restrictions mais aussi des
concessions
l'interdiction de vente de aux mineurs
pour le tabac et l'alcool mais aussi
ouverture à la pub sur internet pour
l'alcool santé publique ou lobby qui
sort gagnant anaïs booba tient la santé
publique dont le projet de loi bachelot
c'est d'abord lutter contre l'alcoolisme
chez les jeunes
première mesure interdire la vente
d'alcool aux moins de 18 ans contre 16
auparavant
interdiction également de la vente au
forfait c'est à dire les open bars
objectif lutter contre le binge drinking
autrement dit la défonce le plus
rapidement possible avec l'alcool la
filière viticole a néanmoins obtenu ce
qu'elle voulait l'interdiction de la
vente au forfait ne s'appliquera pas
dans les dégustations et foires aux vins
toujours dans le même but la vente
d'alcool dans les stations-service est
restreinte
il n'est plus possible d'y acheter de
l'alcool entre 18 heures et 8 heures du
matin
parallèlement à toutes ces mesures la
publicité pour l'alcool sur internet est
autorisée
bien que contrôlée elle ne pourra pas
être intrusive autrement dit elle ne
pourra pas utiliser les spams et les pop
up
autre cible de roselyne bachelot le
tabac les cigarettes bonbons c'est à
dire les cigarettes parfumées à des
arômes sucrés sont interdites autres
interdictions la vente de tabac aux
mineurs mesure purement symbolique selon
les buralistes parce que difficilement
applicable enfin l'obésité devient une
priorité de santé publique plusieurs
mesures ont été adoptées notamment la
possibilité d'acheter des fruits et
légumes avec des tickets-restaurant mais
un amendement ump a été repoussé il
visait à interdire la publicité pour les
produits gras et sucrés dans les
programmes de jeunesse voilà depuis
mercredi un livre sort les socialistes
publient leur petit livre des libertés
publiques
une sorte de best-of anti sarkozien sous
la forme d'un abécédaire
parmi les dénonciations les reconduites
à la frontière du gouvernement la
politique sécuritaire les atteintes aux
libertés des médias la réforme de la
justice ou encore l' équilibre des
pouvoirs laurent fabius ce genre
d'offensive sociale et c'est là quel
impact sur l'opinion publique vous
rencontrez bien l'opinion sur ces sujets
là je ne sais pas je ne peux pas me
prononcer là-dessus ce que je sais c'est
que healy a évidemment l'aspect
économique et social qui pour nous comme
pour la population complètement
fondamental est de ce point de vue là la
politique de sarkozy est malheureusement
inefficace et injuste
on constate mais il y a aussi ses
dimensions des libertés n'ont pas du
tout que la france une dictature il faut
pas non plus exagérer mais prenez dans
le domaine des médias il ya quand même
beaucoup de recul on l'a vu en matière
de visuels ou dans le domaine du
parlement il ya une révision tous les
français n'ont pas traumatisé par la fin
de la pub sur france télé mais dans la
pub c'est une chose mais la nomination
des dirigeants par le président de la
république c'est autre chose ça c'est
comme un recul dont 2 c'est ce qu'a
recul évident mais il ya un autre aspect
ici au parlement
on avait dit vas y à une révision
constitutionnelle et du même coup vous
verrez l'opposition aura beaucoup plus
de droits
ça doit bon la révision elle est en
train d'application et on ne voit rien
de tout ça et puis il ya ce qui concerne
la justice avec l' affaire très sérieuse
très préoccupante de la mise en cause du
juge d'instruction n'ont pas que juge
d'instruction soit une institution
parfaite bon il est besoin de plus de
collégialité 1 qu'il fallait la
renvoyant la collégialité mais autre
chose est de dire maintenant
l'instruction va dépendre du ministre et
du gouvernement donc il y a et notamment
contre les jeunes j'y reviens une
certaine mise en cause des libertés et
je pense que il faut faire preuve
d'autorité
c'est important mais respecter le droit
allez on va maintenant passer à la
journée de jeudi on va parler du choc
continental je dis donc la colère des 12
cents salariés du fabricant allemand de
pneus continental ils viennent
d'apprendre la fermeture de leur usine à
clairoix dans l'oise
en cause selon continental la chute des
commandes mais les ouvriers avaient
pourtant accepté en 2007 de repasser en
40 heures pour préserver l'efficacité du
site
reportage sur place avec pierre dont
joseph
à clairoix la tension est montée d'un
cran aujourd'hui devant l' usine
les quelques 1120 salariés de
continental en grève se relaient jour et
nuit pour empêcher aux pneus encore
stockés de sortir de l'entreprise
sauf sauf pour les brûler on voit un ami
après son avec aucune possibilité de
reclassement après 21 ans sur le même
site
enfin en travaillant en trois-huit avec
très peu de formation on est comme ça
donc on est tous sortis avec dc la paix
ou des deux belles choses qui sur le
marché de l'emploi sans le feulement
dérisoire encore sous le choc de
l'annoncé de la fermeture les salariés
qui avait renoncé il ya deux ans à peine
aux 35 heures pour préserver l'emploi se
sentent aujourd'hui trahis
mais l'injustice relayés au micro par
les élus locaux réunis ce matin la
mairie pour soutenir les salariés aient
compris par le très libéral philippe
marini la crise
mesdames et messieurs mes chers
collègues la crise elle a bon dos vous
devez interdire c'est vous qui votez
vous devez faire interdire les
licenciements d'entreprises qui font des
bénéfices bien d'abord dès qu'il y aura
un président du conseil de surveillance
chez continental puisque actuellement le
siège est vacant allé le voir pour
remettre en cause d'abord cette décision
de fermeture qui est mal prise qui est
mal motivée qui n'est pas mon avis pas
conforme au droit du travail
la fermeture pourrait être attaqué en
justice pour délit d'entravé
une accusation récusée par la direction
qui a mis en place une cellule de
soutien psychologique est recruté dans
le même temps 50 vigiles pour empêcher
ces salariés de toucher aux stocks de
l'entreprise et jeudi on reparle aussi
de l' affaire pérol une affaire qui
rebondit il s'agit vous savez alors un
petit mot je comprends tout à fait que
les salles soient écoeurés
parce que leur demander un gros effort
et puis voilà le résultat
et en même temps je peux pas m'empêcher
de dire quand on rapprocha du slogan de
la campagne présidentielle travailler
plus pour gagner plus quand même triste
vous semble pourtant être un peu écarté
voilà pour cette bohème réaction j'en
reviens à cette affaire pérol l'autre
actualité de jeudi pour ceux qui l'ont
peut-être oublié il s'agit vous le savez
du secrétaire général adjoint de
l'elysée nommé à la tête du groupe
caisse d'épargne/banque populaire alors
la commission de déontologie n'a pas été
saisie de cette affaire et son président
olivier fouquet était auditionné à
l'assemblée jeudi vous allez l'entendre
il était très énervé ce jour-là énervé
d'abord bien sûr contre le président
sarkozy énervé aussi contre les
socialistes qui selon lui s'implique un
peu trop dans cette affaire le récit de
cette audition très mouvementée avec
anaïs booba tian
les députés ps avaient une idée en tête
passer sur le gril olivier fouquet le
président de la commission de
déontologie a dû expliquer sa position
dans l' affaire pérol
et ce n'est pas chose facile les
échanges furent vifs
objet de la colère le mémoire de deux
députés socialistes adressée à la
commission de déontologie
vous comprenez diaz dans les pays
soviétiques au biac dans les pays
soviétiques côté soviétique qu'on
intervient comme ça je vous dirais
réaction des membres de la commission
j'ai été j'ai été j'ai été sept ans j'ai
été sept ans j'étais je suis désolé je
vous dis ce que tu dis finalement les
esprits s'apaisent
olivier fouquet met en lumière les
manquements de la loi la commission de
déontologie ne peut pas s'auto saisir
les députés socialistes ressortent de
l'audition avec une certitude
olivier fouquet aurait été
instrumentalisé par nicolas sarkozy le
président de la commission de
déontologie a adressé un courrier au
chef de l'état le 23 février dernier
il stipule que la nomination de françois
pérol à la tête du groupe caisse
d'epargne banque populaire ne posait pas
de problème d'incompatibilité
ils ont le sentiment d'une
d'une institution qui a subi des
pressions considérables qui elle même
envisager sa propre démission collective
c'est une institution qui vient d'être
écrasé par le pouvoir pour faire passer
un abus de pouvoir
je suis choquée est un juriste éminent
me fouquet ne s'est pas aperçu je crois
parce que c'était pas un politique qu'il
était en train de se faire manipuler par
le secrétariat général de l'elysée par
le président de la république lui-même
et il n'a fait qu'appliquer la loi avec
comme l'a très bien dit michel sapin qui
est l'auteur de la loi de 93 qu'il y
avait des ambiguïtés dans cette loi et
qui est qui qui qui a fait aujourd'hui
que nous sommes dans une situation
totalement irréaliste et inadmissibles
les ambiguïtés de la loi devrait être
réparé jean luc warsmann a indiqué qu'il
ferait dans ce sens une proposition de
loi très prochainement qu'est ce qui est
vraiment choquant dans cette affaire
pérol laurent fabius un petit mot pour
dire que le parlement l'autre jour
c'était la commission des lois est tout
à fait dans son rôle en faisant ce genre
de mission parce que ça nous a appris à
tous savourent nous
la réalité et je voudrais que de plus en
plus le parlement joue ce rôle d'
enquête d'évaluation pour alors
maintenant sur le fond la déontologie il
faut résumer quand même mr simple cette
affaire voilà ce qu'à terme général
adjoint dg que je ne connais pas qui
négocie un prêt de 5 milliards d'euros
d'après ce qu'on dit vis-à-vis d'un
établissement plus bancaire et c'est le
même secrétaire général de l'elysée qui
a négocié le prêt qui est celui qui
valent encaissés comme président de
cette société
si ça ne pose pas un problème
déontologique alors qu'est ce que c'est
que le mois d anthologie
je me prononce pas sur la commission
elle même c'est une autre affaire mais
on est en pleine affaire d anthologie
c'est dans une situation économique
particulière c'est la crise l'état au
nouveau dans l'économie des bancs et met
donc ça justifierait des situations que
ses besoins
non non il n'y a rien qui justifie que
la personne qui au nom de l'état négocie
à près de 5 milliards avec ce que cela
suppose des discussions et à soi après
celui qui encaisse le chèque ça c'est
pas possible
bon c'est le premier pratique avait lieu
sous la gauche aussi on retrouve à aider
des directeur de cabinet à la tête de
grands noms n'ont jamais rija mais dans
ces conditions on a cité par exemple
dans mon cas donc je suis sensible ce
louis schweitzer qui est devenu un grand
président de renault mais lorsque
monsieur schweitzer est parti de mon
cabinet après les élections d'abord il
n'a pas été du tout nommé président de
renault il a été nommé
outre aux leurs de la gestion de cet
arbre et c'est plusieurs années plus
tard en tant que ea ayant monté dans
l'entreprise et d'autre part il n'y a
jamais eu un prêt de 5 milliards
négociés par monsieur jouer des airs et
qu'après il aurait touché le président
donc ça arrive à quelque chose
aujourd'hui à l'arsenal législatif
français sur ce sujet là où et surtout à
la pratique orale d intéresser bon ça
c'est le premier point deuxième point on
a dit mais il fallait que ce soit ce
monsieur parce qu'il est hyper compétent
et c'est bon là je crois qu'il ya une
petite confusion bon ce monsieur est est
inspecteur des finances est très bien
d'autres inspecteurs et science mais ça
ne vous rend pas nécessairement que
compétent pour présider une
établissement panthères de plus de 100
militaires sur les rails devant demande
d'affaires à l'ancienne banque
d'affaires que vous le savez une banque
d'affaires ça n'a rien à voir avec
d'établissement de 5000 personnes et
dans cette banque d'affaires dont il ya
certainement très bien réussi mais j'ai
compris ferrer que l'une de ses
créations ça a été le groupe natixis et
se monte à tecsys est précisément
l'origine de la difficulté financière
des caisses d'epargne de moralité et de
compétences pour résumer la chose au
pluriel et troisième problème qui est
peut-être le plus important quand vous
regardez attentivement mais souvent bien
trop superficiellement ce qu'apporte
l'état dans cette affaire dont l'état
apporte plusieurs milliards d'euros nono
mesure et qu'est-ce qui prend en échange
en contrepartie deux administrateurs sur
beaucoup et des éléments qu'il ne lui
donne pas le droit de vote et donc moi
je suis très interrogatifs et même
choqué comment est il possible qu'on
apporte autant d'argent et qu'on n'ait
pas une contrepartie donc voyez cette
affaire est très compliqué et je n'en
sais monsieur perron ne sais pas encore
j'ai un peu la légère parce que les
textes quand on les regarde montrent que
il risque d'y avoir des suites pénales
ça poserait des problèmes à tout le
monde il sera auditionné à l'assemblée
nationale dans les prochains pourrait
lui poser toutes ces questions en
attendant pass à la journée de vendredi
avec ce dérapage verbal dans l'hémicycle
vendredi beaucoup de réactions et
d'émotion après l'incident qui a opposé
dans la nuit
l'opposition à la ministre de la culture
christine albanel albanel sur la
création d'une haute autorité concernant
internet le mot trop dans l'hémicycle
desta peau le récit de julia le caureq
gestapo
le mot est lâché la ministre de la
culture christine albanel
excédé par les allusions répétées des
députés de l'opposition sur la création
de la haute autorité de protection des
droits sur internet
allusion voilée à une autorité qui selon
eux est d'un autre temps
christine albanel visiblement exaspéré
se lâche et je trouve qu'elle est
vraiment une peinture extrêmement
caricaturale qui est faite de ce projet
qui est parfaitement respectueux des
libertés la caricature affreuse qui
consiste à présenter cette haute
autorité composée de magistrats à partir
de la rt comme une sorte d'antenne de la
gestapo est particulièrement ridicule
choqué l'opposition lui demande de
retirer ses propos
je retire la mangue est à pau d'accord
je retire la mode est à pau l'opposition
qui montent au créneau par la d'atroces
dérapages et si mu de l'évocation de
cette période douloureuse comme j'étais
bouleversée par vos propos madame
ministre
écoutez moi chers collègues vous
comprendrez pourquoi
accusé les députés de l'opposition que
nous sommes de comparer parce que nous
critiquons votre projet de loi la hadopi
à la gestapo
écoutez chers collègues parce qu'il y
avait les gestapo dans notre pays
effectivement il ya 60 ans la cause de
legata pour moi j'ai jamais connue ma
grand mère paternelle de la séance est
levée sans que les députés n'aborde le
coeur du projet de loi les sanctions
pour li ratage ils en discuteront à la
reprise de l'examen dû texte le 31 mars
d'un brûleur ans à vue c'est un
commentaire sur ce qui s'est passé
madame albanel incontestablement aurait
mieux fait de ne pas prononcer ce mot ce
sera ce havre pour terminer ce sera le
mot de la fin laurent réa bus comment
vous définiriez le contexte politique
actuel
la couleur de cette période très très
grise
bon ce qui nous frappe si vous voulez
c'est non seulement la profondeur de la
crise mais que le gouvernement n'est pas
capable de montrer la perspective de
sortie au fond on peut connaître des
moments difficiles mais la tâche d'un
gouvernement d'un président de la
république c'est de dire voilà voilà ce
qu'on va faire
et voilà comment on va redémarrer et
aujourd'hui non seulement il ya la
difficulté mais le gouvernement n'est
pas sans capacité de montrer leur
démarrage c'est ça qui est le plus
difficile mais ce serait le mot de la
fin merci infiniment laurent fabius
d'avoir été l'invité parlement hebdo on
se retrouve bien sûr la semaine
prochaine même endroit même heure est
notre invité sera emmanuel jean marie
cavada député européen à la semaine
prochaine
je
non dieu vous arrivez à me faire 10
secondes la 10 secondes à dessus c'est
le principe d'une politique réformatrice
la défaite semble ne pas pouvoir
l'atteindre fallait un peu la foire a
été arrêté williams a expliqué qu'on
s'emballe un petit peu vite êtes
d'accord avec ça il n'y a donc pas ce
n'est rien arrivé c'est pas possible
mais ce sera un président américain qui
va nous poser tout un tas de naltchik
est-ce que vous avez pris ce matin au
petit déjeuner toujours mon chef est ici
cinq personnes vivent avec moins de 6
ans est mort et c'est pour vous assurer
pendant le transit sûr que c'est un long
combat c'est un long chemin entre les
lignes c'est aujourd'hui à midi sur la
chaîne parlementaire assemblée nationale
de nouveau invité de nouvelles questions
mais toujours le même objectif vous
rendre la vie plus facile vous aider à
vous y retrouver dans tous ces textes
dont tous ces lois qui régissent notre
société
soyez les bienvenus sur le plateau d' à
nous la république sur la chaîne
parlementaire assemblée nationale
à nous la république ce soir à 19h30 sur
la chaîne parlementaire assemblée
nationale